hey reject nation Greg Alba here dan
cyber dan cyber from that cyber channel
joining me today before he drives all
the way back home eight and a half hours
away and that's just with bathroom
breaks what the bathroom I'm talking
about when I got a poop it is a four
hour excursion great comedy content over
here at the real rejects which jokes
fail and then you try to yes and it Dan
have you ever been an angry yeah have
you ever felt like punching your woman
no I have to Dan that's all we're gonna
watch the rage to gameplay trailer today
have you played rage 1 Dan
I haven't well let's watch this trip
behind this one well if you make a rage
- you gotta amp it up maybe by its
software same guys that did a doom and
Wolfenstein which they've been kind of
like on a roll over the last two games
this may not be appropriate
[Music]
80% of the Earth's population dead ocean
80 person is back on humanity long ago
damn straight it wasn't a war global
warming it was a [ __ ] asteroid ok
bored in this [ __ ] parents murdered
an orphan of this wasteland an army of
mutants are I ever marked it with
maghreb minutes would be all that's left
is hatred
and the need for surviving see part of
growing up was watching everything get
take you out I stood by did nothing I
[Music]
got a rage too and welcome to the world
of rage too in a moment we'll dive
headfirst into the Eaton spaceport
mission where Walker our main
protagonist I'd love to find a rare out
of him it will aid him in his quest to
take down the authority
[Music]
approaching the eating space center
today it might be overrun by bandits the
goal is to be proactive as likely slay
them first before falling down the
EcoPOD from orbit
trying to get him
my god
[Music]
these mix-up of camera angles in this
bad boy
I can't imagine that's what they'll
actually be like but now
[Music]
Oh
oh my god this is what I like to see
it's just ridiculous weapon partage okay
it does feel like more sci-fi doom which
is funny because dude's pretty sci-fi I
mean like like cyberpunk Total Recall
cool so that was a sweet advertisement
for the collector's edition
nice oh damn you can feel those gunshots
I got
Wow there's just a [ __ ] up kind of
game huh yeah
I
I don't know if I want to go back and
play the first rage I think I just want
to jump right to this one because I
don't care I don't think it's gonna
matter okay
[Music]
down wire came
oh whoa
please palm some of these guys yeah
[Music]
I don't know what that grenade is but I
want every game to have
oh hey to do for the commercial I know
him
[Music]
[Music]
enter WK doesn't do this entire
soundtrack I'm Ali
[Music]
[Music]
I am nice spring 2019 that's cool that's
cool when I said the duty Lawton part of
it sorry don't sneeze while I'm talking
Dan I don't sneeze make no promises well
I saw the do part about this video like
there's a style to it that seems very
reminiscent of doom yeah I know doom
sigh five this this has sort of a Mad
Max post-apocalyptic meets a cyberpunk
type of world yeah so I like the
aesthetic to it and I like to how it's
just this dude who's just the most
generic action hero in the world part of
growing up was watching everything get
taken from I'm gonna rage binge it's a
super simple setup and not too difficult
to grasp world you were talking about
just skipping part one and hopping
straight to - this feels like a brand
new game to me but this is gonna feel
like a part - in any capacity you know
it looks great especially considering
before e3 before this trailer dropped
Walmart of Canada leaked this they had
to reveal it early so it's still good to
see that like what they actually showed
versus like what we're finally seeing
with the gameplay it looks it looks
intense man
it looks great it looks like high-octane
visceral kinetic energy I like that what
they were showing here is a shooting and
the different occasional options you get
you know with palming occasionally
driving a car I wonder is there gonna be
enough variety to keep me interested in
wanting to beat the whole game
that's my only question with it was
something a bit doom there's kind of
like the creature designs really keep
you captivated yeah yeah and while this
is gory something like doom is
significantly more gory yeah I'm like
this looks great it makes a great
trailer I'm just wondering this be the
kind of thing we're all getting used to
it after an hour - - and be like I've
kind of over it now hey well it's the
same thing there's always the worry that
the first game was very mediocre no one
really asked for a rage - I'm glad they
did a rage - but there's always this
small worry of that like
sure this trailer makes it look great
but the first one wasn't necessarily
like groundbreaking exactly I love its
software so I'll course give them a
benefit of doubt it's open world which
could be great could also be depends on
what there is to do open world I mean
when they're showing us details of what
the world consists of because it's got
this wasteland vibe more often than not
drawn to when they were showing the
different shots of like the you know
like the same empty vacant spots of land
today yeah the first one tried to take
itself seriously it looks like it's
trying to take itself sniffing is me
life is like a b-movie
yeah they embrace the hell out of that
and make guns that are absolutely
ridiculous and like destructive that
grenade oh yeah singularity grenade
looks amazing and like the explosive
yeah ring thing if they keep that up I'm
in but I'm gonna wait for reviews before
I drop 60 bucks when you go like I got
to pick one game this month I guess I
feel like a guaranteed the first two
hours of playing is gonna be a blast
just wondering after that when I'm not
hanging out and shooting and playing
this game when my buddies are playing
online will I be further invested in it
also they didn't say anything about
co-op so it might just be completely
single-player - that's a kind of
worrisome to me because this feels like
this would be a great co-op case it
would be really fun with two people I
don't know if I do like full like
six-man teams a couple buddies playing
this would be every blast that would be
a blasting black that'd be really fun
alright guys well do you love the first
rage game is it necessary to play it cuz
it doesn't seem like this trailer did
anything then really hint at a part one
yeah we'll just skip it well you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are broken hit the Bell because
that's the only way to know also that
cyber Channel that's I have a challenge
you come check me out
I do gave me sort of stuff and I'm a
really good editor they gave me like
trophies and stuff for it I guess just
throwing his Streamy Awards there huh
I can't be humble anymore I have to I'm
such an ass Ali I'm sorry